let's talk about nightmares because an
interesting study came out at the
University of Montreal scientists
bringing this full circle because they
look into things and give you evidence
and proof of things they found out that
men and women actually have different
nightmares and report different feelings
and emotions during their dreams
nightmares are very disturbing dreams in
which the unpleasant visual imagery and
emotions wake you
bad dreams are very disturbing dreams
which do not cause you to wake up
fear appeared as the main emotion in 65%
of nightmares and 45% of bad dreams and
almost half of all the disturbing dreams
contain primary emotions other than fear
including anger sadness guilt and
frustration women's disturbing dreams
tend to focus on social conflicts like
friendships and romances gone wrong men
more often reported sleep jarred by
disasters weather floods or swarms of
bugs only 1.5 percent of the sampled
nightmares and bad dreams involved
themes of falling I think people always
think of the falling dream have you guys
had the following dream okay so we've
all had it but only one point five
that's a dream and you've had the flood
the flying one's good too I've had that
one dreams I always feel like I can't
land just end up flying and I can't land
or do know how to control them I'm not
scared of like helium so maybe the so
the disaster thing like just in terms of
our our dreams until dude do you have
the disaster dreams and the world come
into an end but I take so much ambien
that my dress completely dissipated
makes me talk I'm gonna sleep redecorate
my house but you know I don't remember
it yeah so it's all fine I don't know I
think that you know men and women you
know if dreams are kind of how we work
through our daily problems yeah I think
that you know we we also have different
spots abilities and see the world to
different eyes I think that's going to
affect our you know subconscious state
yes
do you guys think we don't talk about
our dreams enough because I do feel like
it's the end I can always tell if I have
weird dreams it's because I either was
looking at my phone too late before I
went to bed which I'm trying not to do
now so my brain can slow down or its of
course giving you all this subconscious
stuff that your mind is working through
right but I feel like people don't tell
you someone comes up to you it's like
let me tell you how this dream I had
last night
like anything worse than that but
shouldn't we be talking about it more I
mean I like talking about I think I hear
more women obviously than men do that I
think more women kind of disclose
personal or oh you wouldn't believe what
just happened to me type things anyway
and it's a generalization but I hear
lots of women like I had the craziest
dream last night more frequently than
guys will say it but you know maybe it
is something we should be talking
through just cuz sometimes talking
things out loud help you negotiate it
Plus dreams are weird man I just like
kidding about you guys have any
reoccurring dreams anything that really
like has popped up in this guy that you
always have not you always by often have
dreams of you know forgetting what
you're supposed to say you're all sudden
they throw you in front of the camera
and you've never had the script or now
that was find it weird how sometimes
throughout your day you'll experience
something that'll trigger oh my god I
just had this dream about this last
night and I always that's always so odd
to me that you don't remember your dream
sometimes until halfway through the day
when you have an experience that
triggers that dream or this I just I
just thought about this or yeah so are
you saying dreams could be premonitions
I don't know it may be I'm coming back
to that quantum physics quoted oh wow
we're really bringing full circle what
about you any reoccurring yeah yeah I
said my biggest reoccurring is the
flying I would say about once a week I
have a dream where I'm either in a
flying situation or something that
wouldn't be flying like I'm in a
chairlift for skiing I'm also on the
chairlift is gone and then I'm flying
and instead of most people that I've
talked about flying we're like yeah
flies they're so fun instead of my
immediate concern is how do I get down
roll the flying obviously how do I get
down and then I have a few other
reoccurring ones I have a weird
apocalypse one where I'll be somewhere
and we know the world is going to end
and my reaction is different to know
them sometimes it's calm sometimes I'm
very freaked out by it I have a lot of
reoccurring theme dreams so when I have
a different one it's almost stranger to
me well I can give you the most obvious
reoccurring dream on the planet which is
my main one that I have probably once a
week I'm guest hosting The Daily Show
and it goes incredibly well like perfect
perfect perfect but they forgot to turn
the cameras on that's not a comedy 101
or something right yeah that would be
like the most obvious like you're afraid
you're gonna do something great no one's
gonna see it's gonna be noise I'm Holly
you go through my day and I'll realize
like I'm totally naked and no one said
anything why has anybody said anything
that I'm that means you're very free
yourself everyone's dreams I don't know
what the deeper meaning of these things
are and obviously there's all these
dream books and you can go see dream
consultants but usually if you think
about your dream you know how it makes
you feel yeah I think that's pretty much
how you work it out how does thinking
about this or dreaming about this make
me feel how do I feel bad about it okay
let's work on it do I feel good about it
let's work towards that it's not that
much of any story there yeah so final
thought on this and bringing it back to
this study I guess it shouldn't surprise
us right that men and women have
different dreams we use different parts
of our brains and all that kind of stuff
so that does it not surprise you are you
do you think you have female dreams
sometimes I think I've had some female
dreams if I have them consistently yeah
are you having manly dreams every now
and again I do dream more I feel like
about this stuff the male stuff they're
saying I dream about disasters and
things and more than I dream about
people except for my mother and we won't
get into that because we never leave my
god